so let's give it up for Tom bill you
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody man come on we got to do
better than that I want to know how many
born entrepreneurs do we have in the
crowd all right nice
well I'm very much not a born
entrepreneur and that's very important
to know about me I know a lot of you out
there were selling flowers that you
plucked out of somebody's yard selling
them right back to them or you were
trading baseball cards or selling candy
lemonade stands all of that I was not I
was raised to be a good employee which
meant keep your head down do as little
work as possible and avoid punishment at
all costs and that literally is what my
parents taught me to do and that's what
I thought that a good employee did and
that was really how I started and so
really a bad track for somebody that
wants to ultimately become an
entrepreneur but to be honest I didn't
start out wanting to be an entrepreneur
I wanted to be a filmmaker I went to
film school that was my background I was
obsessed with human psychology that was
really the big driver for me and I
learned a lesson along the way which was
if you really want to control the art
you have to control the resources and so
that began my entrepreneurial journey of
really wanting to be able to make the
things that I wanted to make but to do
that you have to really be in control so
I met these two guys incredible human
beings because there were two things
about myself that I said so I grew up in
a morbidly obese family in Tacoma
Washington and a family that teetered
between blue-collar and white-collar and
I said to myself there are two things
about me that I know somehow in the
future I'm going to make come true one
someday I'm going to have six pack abs
and someday I'm going to be rich give it
up I had absolutely no idea how I was
going to make either of those two things
come true but I really did believe to
the core of my being that I would
someday figure it out so when these two
buff bodybuilder guys who were very
successful entrepreneurs came across my
path and they said Tom you're coming to
the world with your handout and if you
want to control the resources you've got
to learn business you've got to get rich
so come with us we're building this
technology company we
need somebody to be a copywriter and
this was back when I was a good employee
keeping my head down doing as little
work as possible and avoiding punishment
at all cost they brought me into their
world and they said now don't think of
yourself as a copy writer you need to
understand that this is a start-up so
you can have any job that you want in
the company you just have to become the
right person for the job and I was the
first time I really started to think
about skill acquisition and the notion
of do you need to be born with a certain
set of skills or are skills something
that you can acquire and that question
has come to really dominate my life
because so much of my journey has really
been predicated on my ability to
actually acquire skills and so I believe
as a very foundational belief that the
reason that any of us are here is for
one simple reason to find out how many
skills you can acquire that have utility
and then put that utility to the test
now if you're getting good at something
building something that exists in
service of other people you're going to
have the energy and the passion and the
conviction that you're going to need to
actually see it through but it all comes
down to whether or not you actually get
really good at that thing and if you
guys take nothing else away from what I
say today that is the core thesis that
sits at the absolute center of my
universe I believe humans can get good
at whatever they set their mind to and
if you're willing to break yourself in
half you can become extraordinary so my
thing is if you really want to be an
entrepreneur you need to be prepared to
become capable of the extraordinary so
quest nutrition was a reaction so I knew
that I was going to have six-pack abs
and that I was going to get rich I got
into the technology company as a
copywriter and I worked my way up very
rapidly I began to believe and see the
truth of the fact that a human can learn
anything that they set their mind to as
long as you're willing to completely
pour yourself into that and that's
something I cannot stress enough so many
people fact somebody just today in this
room came up to me and said I feel like
I'm doing too much Tom I want to enjoy
my 20s what's your advice to me
my advice is sell your 20s I literally
lost my twenties they were completely
gone I didn't do anything with them
other than work all I did because
understand growing up I did not view
myself as very smart and in fact from a
pure IQ standpoint I'm not that smart
and I'll say that IQ is really the
ability to process data rapidly and I
know that we all want to push it off and
say well EQ is equally important and all
that and it is it's great but having the
raw horsepower if you have it leverage
it and if you don't address it and so I
had to accept that I wasn't one of those
people that learn things really fast so
I had to go head down and do a lot of
work and that was how I moved through
the company so very rapidly I took
myself from being hired as a copywriter
to becoming an owner in the company
through pure sweat equity I never put a
dime into the company but my performance
was so dominant and my desire to succeed
so freakish that the level of value that
I was delivering to the company was
extreme enough that they were willing to
give me a piece of the company so that
they wouldn't lose me okay we'll call
that being a linchpin employee I don't
think everybody needs to want to run
their own company running your own
company takes a certain thing inside
Derrick talked about it in his talk I
think you've got to be driven by
something it's got to be something
that's propelling you forward some
sickness and if you know Batman and if
you know me you know my obsession with
Batman Batman is driven by a sickness
there's this dark thing inside him that
propels him forward if you have that if
there's something that you need to build
and bring to the world that you just
can't shake you can't get rid of whether
you're a born entrepreneur or not just
to me they are very separate whether
you're born entrepreneur not is
irrelevant and I put that to the test
and I worked my way up to the company I
got ownership in the company I became
the chief marketing officer I was making
more money than I'd ever made in my life
and I had six-pack abs and it was
horrific
and I've hated my life and I
thought there's no way it's not possible
that I'm living the cliche of money
can't buy happiness like this is a joke
it's something that you see coming
10,000 miles off so how is it humanly
possible when I
understand the power of money you guys
know people are going to chase money
forever right you get that so when
people tell you stuff about
money not mattering let me tell you
right now it matters and it matters a
lot money is I promise
more powerful than you think not less
but it isn't at all what you've been
told and once you understand the
difference between what you're expecting
it to be and what it actually is then it
can become a useful driver in your life
but when you're just chasing money
unaware of the fact that money is inert
it does nothing money is a facilitator
money allows you to make your dream into
a reality but that's it
if you don't know what you're trying to
build if you don't know what you're
willing to die for money has nothing to
offer you so it really became figuring
out why I felt the way that I did and
the reason was I did not know what my
why was so yes we end up building quest
57,000 percent growth in the first three
years but to understand that you need to
understand why we did it so I was
miserable making the money that I was
making I saw this there's just got to be
a better way I actually went to my
partners and I quit I gave them their
equity back I said thank you very much
but I'm not willing to live this life
I'm not willing to feel miserable inside
that holds absolutely no interest for me
so I was going to go do what made me
feel most alive and as I was driving
home I called my wife I did it I quit
that's it we're never going to be in
that situation again I'm never going to
be depressed because we're going to do
something beautiful
I'm literally pulling into the driveway
at my house and my phone rings and it's
my two business partners
and they say the now-famous words we
could do this without you but we don't
want to that allowed me to reconnect to
something other than the money and for
the first time I felt so at rock-bottom
that I wasn't afraid to tell them the
truth I said here's the truth money
isn't my highest value
camaraderie is my highest value in
business what I actually care about is
that feeling of brotherhood what I
actually care about is feeling connected
to the customer what I actually care
about is tapping into my passion and
building something that makes me feel
alive that's a real reflection of my
actual personality those things I care
about I don't actually care about money
that much and that was sacrilege at that
point in our relationship because we had
all taken a pact that we would always do
whatever was most profitable so if that
meant giving up a family vacation if
that meant going out to meet as a
business trio at 2:00 a.m. on a Saturday
these are all real things that we did
then we did it because we had taken that
pact so saying that was such a shift and
in that moment they said we actually
feel exactly the same way and we felt
that way for a while and in that moment
we all realized that you can get so
myopically focused on the money that you
lose sight of what you're actually
trying to do so you have to answer that
question
who knows simon Sinek all right
incredible human being he has this whole
concept to start with why absolutely
critical understanding why you're doing
what you're doing and I'm going to tell
you in the rest of this talk you're
going to see it throughout everything
that I talk about the world is changing
and I cannot say that emphatically
enough I'm sure there are goggles of
Millennials here Millennials are just
the first wave of a shift that is coming
the world is moving to a commerce style
that is driven entirely by impact what
are you trying to do where the consumer
is going to make a demand that you tell
them what you stand for that you tell
them how you're spending your profits
they want to know and they're not going
to support your brand unless you do that
and we're going to get into that more
and how it should affect your business
and how for those of you that are in
this for the right reasons that really
want to build something that matters and
you're willing to break yourself the
half to pull it off this is the
best news ever but make sure you know
your why what's driving you now we live
in a highly social technological age but
one thing
I want you guys to get very very
comfortable with is the idea from Elon
Musk that once you break a problem down
to its physics you will actually know
what is and isn't possible and I'm here
to tell you as a marketer your physics
is the human mind and if you don't take
the time to study
neuro Anatomy to learn the brain to
understand emotion to read about how
people make just crazy weird decisions
that are totally irrational you'll never
be able to speak the language of your
customer so figuring out social media
which I'm sure is way overplayed in
terms of how we talk about it but way
underutilized in terms of its potential
effect if you can find the humanity in
it the idea behind technology isn't to
form fake relationships it's to
communicate and add value it's to show
people who you really are
it's to get to a world where you're able
to build authentic connection with your
consumer really think about those words
for a second because neither of them are
an accident authentic connection so you
as somebody building a brand you don't
get to hide anymore
in your lonely office with the whatever
8x8 inch window that we saw earlier
you've now got to step forward and as
somebody who I literally lied about my
birthday on my Facebook page because I
was so convinced someone was going to
use it to steal my identity okay I had
no desire to step out front I had no
desire to be the face of the company or
anything like that they hounded me
literally my chief marketing officer a
wonderful millennial hounded me to
finally go out front because what he
made clear was that there are two new
kingmakers which are authenticity and
transparency now why does that matter
because Millennials and Gen Z want to
have impact and they want to know how by
engaging with your company they can have
that impact and so that's one of the
things you're going to need to make
clear in your marketing you'll notice
I'm not yet even talking about your
product I'm talking about the
relationship that you need to build with
your community so how did we get to
fifty seven thousand percent I got so
angry at myself for chasing money and
pretending like I didn't just
I connect with people that I didn't want
to add value that I didn't want somebody
to write in and say your product has
changed my life I was so furious that
I'd wasted so many years of my life
doing that was eight and a half years by
the time we finally sold that company
that's almost a decade of my life
chasing money and at the end of that
decade I said never again and so when we
went into quest we said this is going to
be predicated around delivering value
and that's what we're going to focus on
so showing people how not only your
product is going to deliver value but
how your marketing efforts are going to
deliver value now here's the thing if
you're going to build a business at the
end of the day there is one thing for
all the like Airy wonderful beautiful
stuff I'm talking about building
relationships really connecting putting
yourself out there being authentic you
have to know how to build a business the
rubber has to meet the road at some
point understanding this pyramid of
influence in today's social world is
exactly what you guys need to understand
and this pyramid is exactly how we build
quests into a billion dollar brand from
nothing by the way we bootstrapped it we
started with like ten thousand dollars
we were making the bars by hand in a
kitchen that we rented by the hour it
took like eight or nine people seven or
eight hours to make 1200 protein bars we
now make 1.5 million a day okay scale
but how did we get there and how do we
get there so fast the pyramid of
influence at the top or the thought
leaders it's the people most people
don't understand okay they're very
bright and they literally they're the
ones winning the Nobel prizes but
they're not easy to understand for the
average person influencers are the band
of people that pay attention to the
thought leaders but make it accessible
to the masses now the influencers in a
highly social age is the boon to your
business and if you can find them it's
how becoming an entrepreneur has been so
radically democratized your job is to
find you one thousand screaming fans
find the most influential thousand
screaming fans that you can people that
really resonate with your product they
love it they use it so for us at Quest
we literally gave the product away and
we would write you want to talk
unscalable we would want right
well-researched letters to each of these
people showing them that we knew who
they were that we knew what they were
trying to bring to the world and we
thought that our product would give them
the unique ability to offer something
wonderful to their community and that we
didn't want to control their message if
you hate it tell people you hate it if
you love it tell them you love it all we
ask is that you talk and because we
didn't try to control the message people
felt way better about it now when people
think about getting influential people
they normally think of these guys but in
the way that things have changed you
should be thinking of people like this
now I'm guessing most of you don't know
any of the faces there but I'll give you
an example of a social influencer
anybody know jenna Marbles all right
crazy that will say that was about 10%
of you she reaches over 20 million
people a day 20 million people a day how
did we get her to post with our product
a huge stack of product by the way so
somebody with a reach of 20 million
that's like primetime TV how did we get
her to post a photo for free with all of
our products we knitted sweaters for her
dogs because she's huge into her dogs
okay so you want to identify your
influencers you want to add value to
them in their community engage with
their content figure out what it is it's
meaningful to them and make sure that
you do it go above and beyond sending
huge stacks of products for her along
with the sweaters for her dogs for her
which is over above and beyond nobody
had done it and then your goal is to
build those relationships into real
partnerships where it starts with
getting to know each other having
something in common and it becomes
building a business all right don't mark
it build a community there are a lot of
ways that you can engage with your fans
but the goal for you guys is to really
get in there give content that delivers
value to them engage with them reply to
them look at their page give contextual
responses it is a lot of work but when
you do that people
feel really known and understood and you
can get them talking to each other which
is incredible I could do a whole
hour-long talk just about how to do that
and then make amazing impactful content
that is really I think the thing that's
most overlooked your content has to
crush and there's just no shortcuts to
that when people ask me what the
shortcut is to making amazing content I
know they're going to fail let that sink
in if what you're looking for is the
shortcut I know you're going to fail
stop asking yourself how little you can
get away with and start asking yourself
how much you can bear at the end of
every talk that I give I will stand out
in the lobby today included and I will
answer your questions for as long as
there are questions to answer
I've done it for eight hours in the past
until the last question is answered I
will stand there that's how you add
value to your community all right what
if I told you guys your customers hate
your content don't sell you need to find
a way in today's world the marketing in
and of itself needs to be awesome it
needs to be something that I want to
watch I want to consume to add value to
my life so if you look at the show that
we do it's called impact Theory impact
theory we don't charge for it's not a
revenue generator but the number of
people every day that write me and say
you've changed my life with the people
that you've interviewed on that show
you've changed my life I'm going to
start a business that I wouldn't have
started without that I'm getting out of
a depression that I was worried was
going to consume me now imagine I can
build a hundred thousand people that
believe I've changed their life a
million people that believe I've changed
their lives ten million people that
believe I've changed their life what can
I do with that when you switch your mind
from I want to sell something to they're
going to want to buy something just to
be deeper in this community that's when
it gets interesting and when your
product is real when your product
delivers real value whether it's a
suitcase whether it's a protein bar
whether it's a t-shirt it doesn't matter
if you're delivering real value and they
feel like you have
materially improve their lives they're
going to be with you and then I'll leave
you with this do cool there's
literally no substitute for it and I
hope that you will leave today
understanding that you're not yet the
person you need to be to succeed and
once you can embrace the beauty of the
journey of becoming that person the
person that is capable of executing at
the highest level the person who is no
longer worried about getting a
championship ring and instead they are
focused solely on becoming capable of
the championship performance then you'll
win and that brings us back the reason
you are here is to find out how many
skills you can acquire and put them to
service for something greater than
yourself you do that you'll build a big
business thank you
[Applause]
[Music]